I don't know if it's the most important
story in the country right now I mean
it's not but I but it is at least the
funniest and so you know all about Sam
Britton he's the former Biden energy
official who uh liked to cross-dress and
called himself they them and was also
into bestiality role play and all kinds
of other sick and insane things that
none of us needed or wanted to know
about but we do now
um and he's also the guy who got fired
after stealing luggage from uh what we
thought was uh only only two women on
two separate occasions
it stole their luggage right out of the
airport out of the baggage claim now
I told you at the time that that you
know this guy pretty clear to me
stealing the luggage he's not stealing
it because he wants the luggage right
nobody needs that much baggage
especially someone like him already who
already comes with so much baggage to
begin with but it's very clear that he
is doing this and he's targeting women
because it's all part again of the sick
twisted fetish uh he has a thing for
stealing and wearing women's clothing
that was clear to me and that brings us
to this tweet from a woman named Asia
com comes in I think we'll just call her
Asia hopefully she's okay with that uh
here's the tweet
and
um
we'll see can we pull tweet up there it
is so my name is Asia Tanzanian fashion
designer based in Houston Texas USA I
lost my bag in 2018 in the DC airport
recently I heard the news on Fox news
about Sam Britton luggage issue
surprisingly I found his images where he
wore my custom-made outfit which was in
the Lost bag in 2018.
and then you can see the uh the dated
photo of her in the dress in 2018 and
then you also can see Brenton in uh in
the exact same outfit so it's a rather
distinct outfit um it's uh very distinct
because she made she custom made the
outfit she's a fashion designer and her
luggage goes missing in 2018 four years
ago and then Britain terms up wearing
her custom clothing you know it it's
it's pretty close to a case closed on
this thing
so what this means is that there he is
and I said apparently he's also wearing
this wrong he's wearing it I think he's
wearing it backwards or something he
doesn't even know how to wear the wear
the outfit
what this means is that Brenton
the baggage bandit has been patrolling
our airports for years he's been lurking
in the baggage claim area like some kind
of uh predatory you know forced creature
on the prowl this is like when when all
the small dogs and cats in a
neighborhood start going missing and you
know that there must be a coyote in the
woods except this coyote steals women's
luggage and then parades are out in
their clothing
um so when we say
here's what makes this so uh apt is that
when we say that these men are
appropriating the female identity well
he was literally doing that right I mean
we were saying that about Sam Brenton
when he was first hired and and we were
supposed to applaud him
and I know I said many other people said
that he's making a mockery he's
appropriating Womanhood and all the rest
of it like we didn't realize how
literally correct we were he's actually
stealing their clothing and putting it
up
yet nobody ever connected the dots
that's what's interesting
at least we don't think they did you
know I like to imagine that there was
maybe one detective somewhere out there
who was uh at the station late one night
smoking cigarettes and drinking black
coffee and pouring through all these
missing baggage cases and then uh you
know he realized that it was all done by
one man and that there was a criminal
mastermind on the loose and he had the
bulletin board up with all the newspaper
clippings and the you know and the uh
and the lines connecting them and all
that and he realized that it was Sam
Britton the entire time and he tried to
make the arrest but the brass at the
station stopped him that's what I like
to imagine happened anyway and if it
didn't happen then someone should make a
movie where something like that does
happen all I know
is that now
like we are seeing the beginning of a of
a new metoo movement
except that in this case it's just women
coming forward because Sam Britton stole
their baggage it's gonna be it's a whole
me too thing now
Sam Britton is the Harvey Weinstein of
cross-dressing
baggage thieves he's the uh
he's the Bill Cosby of baggage claim is
Sam Britton and I just hope that more
women have the courage to speak out
it is like it's in all seriously it's
pretty disturbing too can you imagine
like you lose your baggage and then and
then this creep then you know this creep
turns up wearing it
um so stay tuned
more on that I I will say if you're a
woman if you're a woman who has lost
your baggage at any point in the last
decade anywhere within the continental
United States or probably or probably
anywhere else in the globe we don't know
how far this conspiracy stretches but if
you're in that category I would start
looking through
well
let me stop myself I was going to say I
would start googling images of Sam
Britton to see if you can find him
wearing your clothing but if you do that
you're going to see a lot of other
things about Sam Burton that you don't
want to see so
never mind you know what maybe it's
better just not to know you probably
don't want to know and all you could do
now is
move on with your life
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block if
you're not a member yet become a member
and use code Walsh at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]